[Music]
[Music]
foreign
hey it's us again look it's dark again
it's dark it's
light it doesn't [ __ ] make any
goddamn sense well you know what okay so
whatever it wants to do earlier today
hopefully the microphone sounds okay
because earlier today i swear to god i
touched nothing i did nothing
and then i was going to make a video
today like one of my book reviews
and i went to record it and then i was
just like i had a little voice in the
back of my head going
you better do a test so i did a test and
then i listened to it back and it
sounded like ass
yeah and then when i went and checked
the settings not the settings on the
microphone the settings on the computer
for the microphone
uh it had turned it all the way up again
yeah i did not touch that
i did not do anything to it so i have no
idea
why this is your fault it's your
poltergeist is haunting
my [ __ ] louie says it's not good that's
good that's
asking if this is the damn watch along
the way it's a review man yeah we don't
do we ought to do watch along sometimes
like
i've kind of thought about doing that
it's just the logistics of it kind of
give me a headache but
that would be two and a half hours
because this movie's in two parts is two
and a half hours it is yeah i have
thought about that too but like
especially
when we're watching like like when we
were watching gargoyles the other night
yeah i was just kind of like oh it'd be
funny if we did kind of like a watch
along because we make a lot of funny
yeah like when we're watching the [ __ ]
paid in there yeah you can't do the
audio or anything you'd get
canceled they [ __ ] shut the chair
well no well what you can do i've seen
people do it and it's like it's
basically
you can show like tiny clips but you
basically just show your faces and you
can have the
you know the audio maybe in the back but
just like really really low
yeah you know what i mean i've seen
people get away with that but
i don't know i don't know if i'd risk it
because it does seem like copyright is
kind of a big issue louisiana sandra
sophie yeah
yeah everybody's badgers man david june
is in
that's who gave us this movie yeah david
jude sent us a good show because we were
talking about i don't even remember what
show we were talking about
but let's see yeah the batman triple
feature yeah batman the dark knight
returns part one and two and batman
basket of phantasm which mask of the
phantasm i saw a long time ago but i
don't remember that much i remember it
being really good but i haven't seen it
we haven't seen that one we haven't
watched that one yet but i saw it a long
time ago like many years ago
oh yeah and uh it was weird because when
you go to the title screen on this
i thought it would be the three sections
yeah like part one part two one two
three i thought there'd be three
but there's two and if you just if you
pick the first batman when it plays part
one and two
just back-to-back without yeah see i
didn't even i thought it was just one
long movie i didn't even realize
that it was supposed to be in two parts
no i was just at some point
we were like two hours and i'm like wow
this movie is kind of long
this came up a couple weeks back when i
was talking about superman red sun
that's right which uh was it's a it's
dc animated um movie
about commie superman what would happen
if uh what happened if super baby
fell in the soviet union during the
copper baby something called [ __ ]
super babe
what would happen if super baby fell in
the soviet union under the time of
stalin and grew up economy what would
happen
and uh it's funny because then you then
you show you get to see
you know russian batman and then uh
russian wonder woman
no she's not right here that's right i
say that every time but she's she's
still from the isle of lesbos
she says she she come from a island
there's no men and [ __ ]
superman that's nice red sun's like uh
oh oh i get it yeah yeah oh he's trying
he's trying to do
yeah he's trying to date him and um
during when i was talking about that i
kind of made the comment
that this subject matter and this
material you know the source material
is is animated it's it's comics and
the topic makes more sense to me
in animation than it does say
live action because most of those marvel
movies that i saw
most of the dc live action movies
nah some of them i like but they're just
especially the marvel ones they're just
[ __ ] bland um
just a big spectacle but remember how
rad into the spider verse was because it
was animated it was animated though man
i loved it
i liked it i liked that a lot and i
liked shazam it was live action but it
kind of felt like a cartoon yeah because
it was
it was it was goofy silly but it was not
and uh saw red son like that like that
so david june um suggested this one
and he sent it to us for review so we
just
we just saw the batman one we didn't see
that what's that what's the second
of the fantastic we've seen yeah we just
saw the dark knight returns yeah
and uh it was good
it was good i enjoyed them i enjoyed it
i did as well the uh
peter weller who's the guy who played uh
[ __ ] robo robocop
damn a lot of movies robocop is batman
now yeah he does batman and then a bunch
of other people you know are in there
it's it's it's uh the story takes place
when batman's old it doesn't say how
according to wikipedia he's supposed to
be 55. and commissioner gordon
is 70. because i looked it up too
because i was like okay so this came out
of two parts it went direct to dvd and
play didn't play theaters or nothing
now dc animated universe i guess this is
the 15th
movie so they've done a [ __ ] ton before
this this comes from a 1986
comic book yeah the frank miller one now
this is the same it's a different
timeline i guess in some of the movies
uh this is the same timeline as batman
year one
okay so even though it's 1986 uh bruce
wayne is 55 years old it's funny because
they were talking about him like he was
old
he's only four years older than me [ __ ]
year old
he's [ __ ] acting like he's acting
like he's an old man
you know i thought he's like oh my
sciatica yeah yeah i thought
i thought he was like 65 you know what i
mean i thought that's how old maybe he
was
but um he's [ __ ] drawn out to be
pretty huge he runs into selena kyle's
also known as batwoman
originally that woman uh she's uh she's
fat
she's fat running the damn hooker agent
and uh that means i think that maybe
laughs
i was like oh [ __ ] joker tied her up
[ __ ] dressed her up as wonder woman
and tied her up
just to humiliate her [ __ ] funny
pose had had uh
joker was in it and uh he was being all
effeminate and everything but he was
kind of [ __ ] crazy
uh he did some he did some [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ] yeah he
he killed a lot of people in this
cartoon
robin shows up in it robin's a girl
she's like a
uh well she's like robin 2.0 or robin
3.0 i guess because i think he had
another protege
because he referred to it i didn't see
the movie that was before this but i
guess like before this he had a protege
called jason todd
yeah and that and that dude got killed i
guess
and so now this girl she's supposed to
be thirteen actually uh
she's thirteen yeah oh [ __ ] that's
inappropriate
because i thought she was supposed to be
a college student i thought her friends
i thought that too because
well yeah i thought they were all living
in the dorm or whatever but i don't know
wikipedia said she was supposed to be
there
maybe they changed it from the uh from
the comics i don't know
i thought she was in the college dorm
and she was doing a bunch of acrobatics
and stuff
um but she's wearing like the uh the
old-fashioned robin costume with the
little booty shorts and [ __ ]
well yeah the one a man should never be
wearing okay well it looked pretty good
on her i thought yeah it looked good
and what's funny is even though she's
animated yeah she's animated
and she's kind of like she's i think he
probably called it like genderqueer
she's one of those where she's kind of
like you can't really tell she's a boy
or girl she's she kind of reminds me of
a youtuber called milo
and she's this my you'll see what i'm
talking about
just like that doesn't she the way she
was drawn
reminded me of the way that um on the
old like animated the real ghostbusters
show yeah the way that they drew
um what's-her-face the the girl that the
woman that worked for them
[ __ ] man her name just went right out of
my head any pot player in the movie
which kind of reminded me of the
girl from scooby-doo oh yeah yeah
she's a little she had a little bit of a
velma going on too like like velma but
thinner
and she had like and she had daphne
colored hair yeah kind of like a boy
but uh i think it's just pretty cool
character i guess
yeah i like that although the thing is
is that well they kind of they kind of
goofed on her because she comes up out
of nowhere without any training at all
and tried to stop some crime and [ __ ]
it up
because there were no crimes being
committed and
it's you see that's why i'm saying that
it's it's better
i think these these movies are better
animated
they are yeah because the [ __ ] that
happens in a superhero movie
is so implausible that it just doesn't
translate to
live action very well for me you know
what i mean because it's just
too [ __ ] implausible you got a girl
with absolutely no training [ __ ]
jumping on a bunch of armed criminals
and [ __ ] beat and beats up like six
of them and the dudes had assault rifles
you'd be a [ __ ] dead man batman was
doing [ __ ] like that
and would they must have fired two 300
rounds of batman in one scene they
didn't [ __ ]
hit him a single time batman he get
grazed
batman's super power is that he always
picks enemies who can't shoot
[ __ ] right now that's a very important
super power to have
yeah when you see amazing luck like that
or amazing
you buy it you understand it more when
it's animated because you're not
expecting realism yes it's a cartoon
it's just emotion
you know yeah but when you show that
[ __ ] live action
you know what i mean it strains
credibility
you know that's like the problem with
the mandalorian and star wars where you
got
30 [ __ ] storm troopers shooting at
you and all these laser bolts and they
can't hit anything you know although
they did kind of clown on that a little
bit yeah which i like because that's
you know in the fandom i just feel like
that's something everybody clowns on
because
troopers can't hit anything well it's
probably hard to see in those helmets
[Laughter]
if you had helmets like that in that era
it would be part of your targeting
system so you'd have to
it would be but you would actually be
able to aim better you would think
that's how they would really do that
there'd be a holographic sights in there
and all kinds of [ __ ] and communications
and night vision goggles and [ __ ]
it's also a
gas mask it's everything in one you know
with star wars level technology that
mask would be badass
yeah because just look at what the
mandalorian could do and everything
we're getting off track
[Laughter]
okay we're getting on track imagine that
yeah but yeah so like i said
um i didn't know a great deal about this
going in i had seen masking the phantasm
but that was like so long ago that i
barely remember it
um and that i don't even think that's in
the same continuity oops i could be
totally wrong about that but um but so
yeah so we were watching it
and it i don't know like it kind of
struck me at some point that i'm like oh
it's going off in this direction now
and now now there's superman and now
there's joker and now there's other
stuff because
you know the beginning of it had been
mostly the the mutants you know the gang
that all looked like
out of the 80s from a 1981 like terrible
music
in the 80s it is it's 86 yeah and it
came so it was actually the comic book
was actually written in 1986 so it was
contemporary for the time
right um you know but they just like
said it back then so
yeah the first part of it is like this
gang the mutants and they're just kind
of taking everything over and like i
said they all have those [ __ ] glasses
on looking like [ __ ]
little raven rapper right now like look
in there and devo or some [ __ ]
mohawks and fangs yeah well like the
main guy the head mutant whatever his
name was like he was kind of like
he was almost kind of like not even a
person he was kind of like a monster
i think they were mutants yeah maybe
they were actual me
yeah i guess because he was like this
just this big like a sharp teeth
and he had liquid unless he'd filed all
his teeth down methodically
but he actually looked kind of more like
a monster than a person
uh but yeah so they were kind of taking
over they're doing like terrorists he
kind of [ __ ] like trying to take over
gotham and
um you know batman had retired because
of jason todd his previous uh
you know his protege dying which had
happened before the events of this movie
so uh for a while like but then you know
while with all the crime batman's like
wait i just i can't stand it i can't
stand it i gotta go back to batman
yeah um even though i'm old he's 55
man you need to get on that trt of
it's in your mind it's just something
happening at the cellular level
that's something dude i don't know man
it just goes
i remember you it used to feel real
[ __ ] uncomfortable to like uh
get down and lay down on the ground and
then get back up i look underneath the
car
look for the cat it's like oh i do it
now like it was nothing
what was the difference you know what i
mean i was i was in shape then
it's just something about your
metabolism is not running the right way
it doesn't have you just
you run out you run down you run down
because you're lacking natural [ __ ]
sustenance
from all them damn hormones yeah bigger
you don't have the vigor
that's what batman needed he needed that
damn [ __ ] needle
he was yeah it'd be fine he had all that
mass he was [ __ ] he must have weighed
500 pounds
if he was drawn to the scale i mean
robin stood next to him and she was like
the size of a small monkey next to him
at one scene like when when they were
hanging off the helicopter or whatever
like near the end i was just like oh my
god he could eat her
yeah yeah she's so small
but um it's the edit was pretty good uh
the voice acting at first i thought was
kind of spotty it took me a while
to kind of accept the voice acting or it
could have been that
it could have been that the actors
themselves didn't feel as comfortable in
the roles in the very beginning
or you weren't used to those voices in
that context
although i didn't have that problem with
red sun red sun immediately fell i
immediately bought it
yeah uh the animation is good the score
is good there's nothing wrong with it
it's a good movie
uh the only thing if if only thing i can
critique it on is that
it's a part one and two and i would have
liked to have known when part one
ended and when part two began i can tell
you right now
well it should have been on the dvd yeah
but i i kind of like that it was all
just one big one
so it could have ended like an episode
yeah you know what i mean and it
and that way you could take a break and
there probably would have been a better
dramatic pause
knowing that that was and that was an
end to that part of it
you know what i mean yeah blending them
together i think just made it seem like
one long
two and a half hour movie and it was
almost kind of
um ponderous
well you could tell that it was two
different movies because i'm saying like
it it's the same overarching storyline
but
the first part of it like i said is more
focused on the mutants gang
whereas the second part of it is more
focused on joker
and the new commissioner and you know
all that kind of [ __ ]
it would have been better on the dvd had
there been an option to watch
just part one and then have it end
credits and then part two or to have it
for you to play it through
you know or you can watch it like it's
like a like a full-length feature
yeah i don't like that option they just
put not too long ago they just put out
like a kind of a
um you know what i mean a deluxe blu-ray
edition oh did it so
maybe you can do that right and it
supposedly has like a whole bunch of
likes
watching it watching the whole thing
just run back to back like that
i think would have been better to watch
it in two separate parts
yeah one on one day and then you sit on
that and then
the second part the next day i can see
that like like an episodic
i think it would have felt better so you
know what i mean
but it did i guess it didn't occur to me
that it was two movies so i was just
kind of like whatever
it was like i knew it was going on kind
of long it says man [ __ ] wonder how
long the second movie is
yeah i just watched it
yeah that is really funny we're so
observant
right but yeah the the end of the first
movie the end of the first part
was when um joker comes out of the
his catatonia or whatever yeah you know
what i mean
and he just like smiles and then the
beginning of the next movie is when he's
on the talk show
which like you said that was just like
oh it's just like the the movie joker
that had joaquin phoenix in it where
he's on the talk show and then he's like
gonna kill all the people in the [ __ ]
in the
audience or whatever i think that i mean
honestly i liked all of this the only
thing that's
that i thought was a little bit weird
and maybe people that you know know more
about the dc universe could tell me
but i felt like the the part with the
mutants that was cool but it's like
i kind of felt like harvey dent was in
there and he got his face
fixed and he was sort of behind some of
the terrorist [ __ ]
but then i think like the last time you
see him you figure out that
even though his face looks quote unquote
normal now he still has this weird body
dysmorphia where now he thinks
both sides of his face look [ __ ] up
and so he wants to die so he's doing
like all this
all these bombings and [ __ ] but then
like after that you don't really see him
anymore
like what happened to him did he die i
don't know i would was that happening
was i not paying attention
so it's like they don't really they
don't really mention him anymore like so
harvey dent's not in it all that much
you know i mean i so i feel like there
was a lot of
there was a lot of build up like for him
being behind all this stuff with like
the mutants and everything but then he
just kind of disappeared
unless i just wasn't paying attention i
thought i was paying attention but i
guess not
sometimes it actually happens so fast
that you you it doesn't really have time
to sink in i'm reading the comments
another thing that um that happened in
it
hold on uh mango asked did mark hamill
do the voice for joker in this no
no he didn't it was uh [ __ ] man i didn't
recognize the dude's name but when i saw
his picture like
on imdb i was like oh yeah yeah that guy
um i can't remember what his name is
though
but i actually really liked his joker
michael emerson michael emerson that's
what his name is i think i think
watching these things animated just
makes more sense like
like all right robin had to
run up the side of a damn roller coaster
in a theme park
you know the side of it that's just not
possible in real life but it makes sense
when you're looking
and also the the the the action of them
[ __ ]
jumping out of helicopters or jumping up
into helicopters or you know using a
helicopter to come grab somebody
it just it seems to flow a lot better in
an animated form
there's no way you could do that with
live action and have that [ __ ] credible
you just yeah everybody be like
you know although like i said i do
maybe you're right because when you see
it there's no expectation of realism
when you're watching a cartoon just art
well and so you can just like chill out
and enjoy it yeah
yeah i kind of feel like i i mean i
don't really have this because when i
watch a movie i'm just like whatever man
show me whatever i'll buy it but um you
know what i mean
as if i'm enjoying the movie if i'm not
enjoying the movie then i'm going to
nitpick
but but when you're watching a movie i
think your brain is just kind of like no
no that can't happen no you know what i
mean so it's like harder to
it's harder to just relax and like let
[ __ ] wash over you yeah
but yeah uh yeah the creepy guy from
lost that's right yeah
i knew he was on he's been on some other
[ __ ] too but yeah he was on lost the guy
that did uh
joker i really actually liked the joker
in this one because i didn't realize
like i said so i thought it was gonna be
all about the mutant storyline and then
the mutants kind of um you know the the
head mutant guy
he kind of like you know him well he
first kicked batman's ass
and then you know so then they had that
fight at the end where he just kicked
the mutant's ass
and then like all the i just thought it
was really funny how all the mutants
as soon as their leader got his ass
kicked like his ass handed to him by
batman
they were all just kind of like oh okay
we're gonna follow batman now yeah and i
was like can't you guys just think for
yourselves
that's not too much to ask they're going
to choose them
[Laughter]
why don't you just go do your own thing
you don't have to be in a gang but yeah
so they
so they do that and then i was just kind
of like oh okay so now
then i thought it was the end which i
guess it was if you were just watching
the first part
but then i was like oh joker neat and
then then it goes off on this whole
other thing with joker and
and all that kind of stuff and uh you
know catwoman and
green arrow was in there too the okay
i'm gonna explain what happened all
right the the reason why
they switched from mutant to batman
is because in the very beginning batman
said that it's basically a hero worship
cult
that they worship him yeah you know and
if you can beat him
that type of guy would prob would
probably switch their loyalty
well yeah that's why it was such a big
deal at the end that he had to like
humiliate the guy too yeah he can't he's
like i can't
i can't just beat him i have to like
make him look like this
make him look like a punk yeah and and
then that's not exciting and they won't
be able to fall
they won't be able to follow him yeah
and then they'll choose me
and that and then he turned him into
what they call the sons of batman yeah
yeah so he had his own he had his own
[ __ ] warrior cult worshiping
although he had to like tell them to
settle down because they were still
doing like all the criminals and stuff
like that he's like hey no that's that
we don't do that here now okay it's like
yeah
but there's another scene where he's
talking to superman and he [ __ ]
they finally kind of that's the first
time in one of these things that they
kind of admit that
well we superman and batman said well
actually
we're criminals too yeah because you
know they're
i mean they're operating outside the law
both of them are you can't be a
vigilante you know and
the cops were after batman and the only
reason why they weren't after super bad
is because superman was for in this
movie was friends with ronald reagan
yes and he was working for america yeah
beating up on the russians on the soviet
union
yeah he was going to like sink in all
their like aircraft carriers
[Laughter]
yeah there was a whole bunch of cold war
[ __ ] on this too yeah mostly in the
second part
which you know that that that that fits
the character because he
was fighting to fight the germans too
fighting the nazis in world war ii
yeah so you know it was mad cartoon
[ __ ] american comic book superheroes
were
war propaganda that's what it was yeah
essentially essentially war propaganda
the during world war ii all the a lot of
the usgis just
read those that's why they had [ __ ]
you know superman fighting the nazis
superman fighting
captain america was fighting uh which is
tojo
and uh emperor hirohito and fighting
mussolini
oh man they even had they even had
cartoons where donald duck punching
hitler
yeah they did all that stuff so go
search that on youtube donald duck
punching yeah and that's really where
sporties in world war ii is really where
um
the superhero actually kind of gained
kind of mainstream
cultural prominence and it was war
propaganda
and then after that after the war it got
attacked because it kind of had
pedophilic overtones eventually
because what's what the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] you grown men running around these
little
kids you know what i mean
and then they got robbing them little
shorty shorts and [ __ ]
it is a little weird and then you know
and every it was really just a trend
because
sales in in comic books started to
[ __ ]
fail so the guys that ran the super
that ran the comic book company said
well you know little kids read these if
we include
the little yeah i think that's all it
was right like it was just like oh i'm a
little oh i get to hang out with batman
and like do all this
you know i get that he's with this
superhero and they're doing this stuff
together
and it did kind of increase in the sales
yeah
sales but it to an adult though it looks
scary it looked [ __ ] sketchy and [ __ ]
you got these rich [ __ ] men with all
these [ __ ]
like batman you know who's he's on the
other side of these little kids putting
him in little costumes and little kids
it's got all these toys and their
mansions and underground it sounds like
michael jackson
you know like michael jackson yeah
that's what it sounds like so
they were looking at that [ __ ] sideways
and they were trying to censor them you
know for bad
for kind of immorality but then they uh
marvel and dc they changed their ways
and they
started putting they started drawing a
little [ __ ] certification on them
like this [ __ ] was certified
good clean fun they took the little boys
out of it
[Laughter]
no more little boys they called the
comic book association of america or
some [ __ ] like that had a little
seal of approval to make their parents
happy they just put that [ __ ] there
well yeah there was no there's no no
it's not there's no legal certification
for that
they just drew that [ __ ] on there going
no it's totally fine totally fine the
little boys are going little jimmy can
read this yeah yeah yeah no worries
that was a pretty genius idea when you
think about it we're self-policing
but uh yeah so uh so yeah this was a
little i guess this was
it's still weird but like i said i don't
know the wikipedia page
said that um that what's her name the
new robin what was her name kit
yeah carrie carrie kelly and uh you know
the wikipedia page said she was supposed
to be 13 but like you said in the
cartoon she seems like she was supposed
to like a college student yes i thought
so
i wouldn't believe too much i mean
because i thought she was living with
or no because they because alfred picks
her up at like a high school or
something at the right time yeah he
picked her up in front of the school and
i'm pretty sure that was a high school
or a college
yeah and i think she was graduating yeah
i mean i thought i don't think she
i didn't think of her as a little little
kid i thought of her as like 19 or
something
yeah yeah that's what i thought too
something somewhere around there because
she was hanging out i thought that she
lived in that apartment with like her
roommate
yeah with her roommate never talking
about going to the protest and
protesting
yeah right they would call him batman a
fascist right so i thought that they
were like college students because
she lived with like this other girl and
the and the other girl's boyfriend or
whoever that other dude was yeah
yeah i thought they lived in an
apartment she didn't live with their
parents or nothing no so you know
maybe well maybe maybe
i don't know i haven't read the comic
maybe in the comics she was 13 and they
were like yeah let's not do that that's
a little weird
we don't want to see like a 55 year old
man hanging out with a 13 year old girl
that's creepy
yeah but uh so maybe they aged her up
for the cartoon i'm not really sure
right uh you know what i mean you could
get away with some [ __ ] in 86 you
probably couldn't get away with nowadays
uh as far as like hanging out with a
local they were more innocent back then
well people were more no more innocent
people were
they just didn't know all the terrible
[ __ ] that people got up to
that would be okay
i mean it was though i think i think it
turned out okay for most of them
yeah but there's always that there's
always that one time when it didn't run
out okay i've written about lots and
lots of yeah i remember back in those
days
in the [ __ ] you know around 95
96 some of the [ __ ] goth dudes
[ __ ] that i knew
were hanging out in the clubs and you'd
[ __ ]
he'd be he'd have some girl in there you
know and they'd lived in together and
you'd find out later that she was like
17
16 17. yeah yeah
but i mean it's a little more successful
there's a big difference between 16 17
and 13. yeah oh yeah big difference and
there's a big difference between
22 year old guy 17 year old girl
55 year old guy 13 year old girl yeah
the difference was
it was like the goth scene i mean
[ __ ] these girls are kind of semi
runaways
from home and yeah yeah [ __ ] hanging
out in clubs and
[ __ ] into like [ __ ] bdsm [ __ ] and
[ __ ] you know what i mean and [ __ ]
yeah music you couldn't tell them apart
from a [ __ ] 25 year old
yeah it's like the same thing so like i
said and like i said once you get into
like the 17 i was
like not that big a deal i don't think
but another it was just another time
yeah but when you're talking about kids
that yeah it's a little weird
but uh yeah so i will say that i did
like the second half better because i
liked
i mean there was man the second half was
like action-packed it was [ __ ] joker
in there
there was superman was in there there
was commies there was
uh batman and superman kicking the [ __ ]
out of each other
green arrow was in there with a [ __ ]
uh you know
what do you call it um kryptonite
[ __ ] arrow
to weaken superman joker's in there
at a [ __ ] fairground just like
shooting people like
indiscriminately and uh you know so
actually doesn't batman kind of sort of
uh
he's kind of sort of killed joker right
at the end
in the tunnel of love yeah i think it
was kind of ambiguous i don't remember
if he grabbed his [ __ ] gun or
something happened
and he basically i think he yeah i think
that forced batman to kill him
pretty much but that scene i think that
was my favorite scene of the whole movie
was like that tunnel of love thing
because he was just like going joker's
just going through going woo
and just like shooting everybody let him
shoot nobody dead and then uh
not only did joker die in the [ __ ] but
after he was dead i guess he had rigged
his body with like all kind of like
rockets and bombs and [ __ ] like that
that was that's like after that happens
like cops were coming and like
the [ __ ] bombs were going off and
killing them as well that his [ __ ]
face all burned up yeah
and then uh you know batman kind of
feeling bad also uh
joker stabbed batman a bunch of times
like in the gut i did not think that he
was going to survive that
because i think even though it was a
cartoon like joker's doing that i'm like
holy [ __ ]
well you know what i mean because it's
like it's a cartoon and it's like i
don't know what happens in this timeline
yeah i'm like batman could die i don't
know
maybe it'd be the end of batman yeah
like i said i don't you know because i
know that there's like several different
uh you know there's several different
timelines because you know different
people have written in that universe i
just like seeing a fat selena kyle
that yeah they needed they didn't know
more of her yeah
i think she was only in like two or
three teens but that [ __ ] was so funny
well because i didn't realize yesterday
you know i love you anyway you know
you're fat i still love you
that oh my god well no that that was
what he meant
but i mean like joker turned up to see
her first because he needed something
from her
i didn't realize because he goes in the
building and this front of the building
says kyle escort service right yeah
and i was like selena come like catwoman
and so like
i i can't believe i remember that but
yeah so joker goes in there and she's
all like fat and like boozed up and
stuff
yeah she's like did she have like a
cocktail or [ __ ]
and uh he said something and he said
something real [ __ ] to her it's like
oh the years have not been kind you know
what i mean
also i like that he had that mind
control lipstick that was pretty red
that he could just like kiss you and
make you do whatever he wanted so yeah
so he got her to do some [ __ ] but yeah
so when batman comes there and finds her
all tied up and looks
in the wonder woman outfit she was in a
[ __ ] bondage [ __ ] puzzle but
for for you guys don't know the guy the
guy who actually i imagine most people
probably know
but the dude who came up with comic
books were always [ __ ]
morally kind of [ __ ] questionable you
know i mean they just they just always
were
parents didn't want that especially back
in the 50s and [ __ ] 40s and 50s parents
didn't want to
didn't want their kids [ __ ] watching
it looking at that [ __ ] um
selena kyle was [ __ ]
written by a dude who was in a bond and
she was a bondage queen yeah that's what
she was the magic rope
to make you tell the truth you know and
she's like a torture queen
she's a lesbian from the isle of
fetish stuff bdsm stuff exactly what it
was
but you know back in the days people
were innocent
the bracelets of truth or whatever put
these on you know
oh and then oh my god yeah
that's some of them a lot of the [ __ ]
[ __ ] that was in that comic strip was
bat
was wonder woman tying up other women
and it's obviously [ __ ] like
traditional [ __ ] bondage ties you
know what the [ __ ]
bondage poses and [ __ ] you know it's
really yeah i can imagine like
little boys like reading those and being
like why am i
oh my god i need something like this
[Laughter]
well it's just fun i don't know it's
just really really funny to me that
i don't know so i guess everybody's
parents were right they were terribly
yeah
then they shouldn't have been reading
edward we got it oh my god i'm so
excited yeah because she's never seen it
she wants to watch it with us
oh so she's never seen it oh so we're
gonna have an ed wood night
i've seen it many many times can i i'm
gonna put on like black and white makeup
and like my vampire wig or whatever
[Laughter]
because i'm double jointed
[Laughter]
what do you think of vampira bella
[Laughter]
i don't think he called him tits i think
he said something else [ __ ] man i
haven't seen it in a couple years
yeah evidently
[Laughter]
calm
[Laughter]
and evidently like a lot of stuff from
the edward movies
is pretty accurate it's [ __ ] well at
least the lore around edward
friends you know what i mean the [ __ ]
the stories of the [ __ ] that they did in
old hollywood well actually he wasn't an
old hollywood it was a parasite trying
to get into hollywood
yeah he was very hungry for cringes
with no money he was in that area and he
ended up doing porn later
yeah like after all the and it wasn't
even good porn it's just like no it was
terrible
girls dancing with tits going like that
in an extra skeleton
he had to have like a theme but he was
just such a way to get around porn
[ __ ] laws
i think it had to be yeah i think the
reason some kind of a
cultural phenomenon with yeah so you
dress
them up like it's education i'm gonna
dress them up like [ __ ] hawaiian
polynesian islander girls and
have them dance until the titties going
like that well right next to a skeleton
you know it's just like it's just like
back in the old days where it's like
they weren't allowed to show
like on tv back in the 70s or whatever
you weren't allowed to show
uh a woman's tits unless she was like in
an african tribe or something and they
didn't wear it you know what i mean
it's like oh if it was on pbs and they
were like yes
like anthropologists or something then
they can show tits but i'm like kids are
tits dude it's like everything
they're all tits just nationally either
show them all or don't show any of them
national geographic made billions of
dollars to sell nothing but just damn
tribal african tribal girl [ __ ] uh uh
editions did you know that yeah yeah i
know we'll be trying to get around that
[ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] well it's like that's the
only way they could show tim yeah yeah
yeah you can't show a [ __ ] just get
out of haiti and watch these girls
sacrifice these chickens you know
nude in the [ __ ] condom blade rituals
then they're like it's anthony we'll
take that we'll take the real curvy one
have her yeah it's the very shapely one
have her
like not the old lady not that one don't
do that
taking pictures that's terrible but no
it's true like i said that's
it's just seeing that always even when i
was a kid that always seemed very silly
to me i'm like look tits or tits
yeah like just show all this it's fine
they're called breasts and everyone has
them that was uh that was rick from the
young ones
but if anybody got free the nipple for
the lads
yeah so if you said i have seen ed wood
a couple times oh i thought you said you
didn't see it
[Laughter]
there's something yeah mango said edward
is one of the greatest films in the 90s
i agree
it was just i i think that the reason
that
edward is still so remembered is because
he was so [ __ ] enthusiastic like he
was just really not
good at what he did but he was just so
happy about it and he was so happy to be
able to do it and so i think that he had
a lot of affection for his
stuff even though it was terrible so i
think that that really kind of
that genuineness kind of shows through
it i think you know what i mean which is
why people still remember him nowadays
and that's what's what that's one of the
things that i like about the movie
edward is that it's so affectionate
yeah everything i put together about the
guy i i think
i think he was more he was more in love
with the idea of being a director
and yeah and having a cast and directing
[ __ ] and being with brown a bunch of
people
i think it was mostly been actually
wanting to learn how to do any of those
things
i don't even i don't even like it
technically correctly yeah no and i
don't even think it had i don't think he
was really doing it even for the money
no he couldn't have been i think it was
so he could run around town
saying he was a director and having a
bunch of friends who were actors and
stuff
and yeah he liked the whole thing
hollywood he was yeah
it was just so he could be a part of
hollywood i think that's all it was
yeah that's what makes most sense
yeah like you said he didn't really seem
all that worried about
he didn't care about the movie no i
don't think so
i mean i think the movie was just a fun
part of it
yeah but the the idea of the movie being
like
super high quality and uh being some
real deep story
no not at all they wasn't interested in
that [ __ ] at all
they were just gonna you know same thing
with [ __ ] bellagos
okay let's knock this [ __ ] out
you know just move the tentacles around
make it look like he's killing you yeah
they're just trying to they're just
trying to have a job you know
oh my god it was like when somebody
[ __ ] knocks over
with that one scene where they were uh
in edward where they were filming
playing nine from outer space and like
tour knocks over the [ __ ]
yeah cardboard gravestone it's like no
one's gonna notice that someone yeah
no one's gonna care or when he runs into
the cardboard wall
you know what i mean like going through
the door well in real life that would
probably happen to him every day
sci-fi and horror horror from his era
was all little kids
yeah so they did he did it
it was i think it was mostly just
hanging out with actors and [ __ ]
drinking in the clubs and going to the
bars
afterwards and yeah just having a good
time having fun driving around
you know having fun probably yeah
all right do you have anything else you
would like to say about
batman the dark knight returns no
yeah i act yeah i actually really liked
it like i said it
it's a it's a tribute to how cool it was
that i didn't even realize i mean i
think i was two
more than two hours into it before i
said wow this is kind of long
like when we kind of realized that it's
like two parts
it came out like i said it came direct
to dvd but it came out i think the first
part came out in
september of 2012 and then the second
part came out in
uh january of 2013. now some people are
saying that they're
coming to edward's defense that he did
try to make good movies that he's being
creative
not saying that he wasn't creative it's
just uh i don't think he had really good
taste and i i don't think he he's not
he didn't have any money or resources
it's one thing
okay i do think that he thought that his
scripts were good stories
i think he just wasn't very
detail-oriented like he thought oh the
story's so good that no one's gonna
notice all these
little technical details i think that he
thought that yeah but then you have to
question you have to question
that concept too because a guy who
wants to make really good movies and
wants to write really good stories
reads books and learns about the craft
on how stories are written
and how stories are structured and how
movies are structured
and uh and he didn't do that so he
didn't do a lot of the background
he was kind of like a carnival barker in
a certain way yeah we'll just do it
we'll just do it yeah we'll just do it
he's like he's got like that it'll all
work out it'll all work out i'd be fine
so he's not do you not talk
he's called a hack director because he
was a hack
let's just do it yeah yeah he didn't
take the time to actually
learn the method yeah he didn't really
have any like technical skill or
anything like that no and uh didn't have
any skills as a writer or anything like
you said i think he just liked the idea
of making movies and he just wanted to
make the movie and have fun and be
around
actors he didn't just want to go through
all the direct yeah
yeah all the all the drudgery of
actually learning how to make a movie
that's hard all right the the the um
the opposite would be a guy who went who
went to the same
uh middle school as i did from dominguez
elementary
dominguez elementary school and that's
um quentin tarantino
he was a couple years older than me but
we we went to school together i vaguely
remember him
um he's uh i remember things about him
uh i thought we were in the same class
but jenny actually did the research and
he had been about two years older than
me
but i did remember him um
he ended up working in the local
uh video store he had no education or
training in movies or anything
but he learned it on his own from
watching movies because he really really
really loved that [ __ ] so he could write
a screenplay because he learned how to
write a screenplay
read books on how to do it um knew
everything about
editing and he did all of this as he
was working in a video store watching
movies
and uh there was nothing really special
about him
other than his dedication to film he
loved that [ __ ]
yeah and if you love something then
you'll learn how to [ __ ] do it
yeah and he was kind of a kind of uh
you know like i said i moved away from
there
at the end of uh seventh grade
all right so my friends jimmy and mike
who stayed there they knew him better
than i did because you know they
they were around there for years you
know and
um they said he was kind of a a little
bit not idiots about what he called
he was uh he's kind of like asperger's
syndrome
yeah he was like that a little bit that
way real nerdy
you felt very uncomfortable being around
him um
he got better though as he got older but
i think confidence your confidence does
a lot for you you know what i mean
success you know breeds confidence so
you changed his personality a little bit
but um
they say he's a good guy
but uh now he taught all that on his own
he talked his way into that job
he talked his way into those studios
yeah
i mean it i can understand like it helps
to go to film school because you have
kind of like a framework and
you know they can kind of point you in
the right direction and you have classes
and have they have
people that are in the industry that can
teach you stuff but if you have enough
[ __ ] determination and love for the
dawn you can do without it you can
you can learn anything on your own
especially nowadays yeah i mean it's
it's very
you know you you just have to you you
have the determination to sit down and
do it
and another thing is that you cannot
teach talent well that's
a habit or they don't yeah he did have
talent and he had drive
he kept you know he just kept doing it
kept me you know
i mean you just wouldn't quit yeah and
sometimes when you just won't go away
they're
you're they're forced to deal with you
basically in a way you know i mean the
thing about it is that
the thing is that i think that anybody
can be taught to make a movie
not everybody can be taught to make a
great movie you know what i'm saying
so it's like you know everybody can
learn could learn the technical aspects
of it but not everybody is going to
like be able to produce anything that's
like graham's like [ __ ] quentin
tarantino mary lynn how many famous
people
did i did i grew up with um also
um you know
you know her as parker posey i knew her
from mississippi
all right um that's uh parker posey
parker's her middle name her first name
is missy
missy posey's her name i was friends
with her brother too she has a twin
brother
who's a who's a boy what do they call
that
fraternal that's fraternal yeah
um see who else bunch of people
yeah a bunch of them bunch of them bunch
of them
a lot of people from bands yeah that's
true
yeah somebody asked we would review the
outlaw josie whales
yeah i can do that one we have that
don't we yeah yeah i thought we did
yeah we did we've only done a couple
westerns we've done i got all the good
westerns
we did uh what you call it did
uh pie plants drip power plants drifter
yeah that's a good
ghost movie a lot of people don't know
that yeah and we've done some newer ones
i feel like we did bone tomahawk and
stuff
yeah um haven't done once upon a time in
the west
didn't do the math no name trilogy yet
there's a bunch of them that we have
yeah we and yeah we actually
josie whales yeah we actually have those
so
yeah i remember really liking them
having done jeremiah johnson
real good one yeah he definitely wants
to do that one yeah
all right you got anything else you need
to add no that's it okay because we've
been man we've been going on almost an
hour
yep sandra she has a brother he is a boy
yeah you didn't get to say that but uh
yeah so i guess what's today it's
tuesday right she's a twin brother who's
a boy i said
yeah well brother implies boy oh okay
that's why that's why she was laughing
my brother
yeah that happens a lot yeah that
happens a lot they were both
super good looking she was she's real
good-looking and he kind of was like
he was kind of like superman he looked
like superman huh yeah he got all the
girls
all of them named chris yeah chris posey
he's cool
real cool well there you go there's
another famous person yeah
all right so it's tuesday today which
means that tomorrow
wednesday is our weekly party stream
now i did say we we're going to talk
about lots of other things on there too
but i did say that i
was going to talk about munchausen
syndrome
because uh it in the poll for the friday
night show
it munchausen syndrome was tied with
creepy disappearances volume 5.
so i said okay we'll do creepy
disappearances on the friday show and
then we'll talk about monster syndrome
on the wednesday show so nobody will
feel like they got ripped off
you know what i'm saying yeah so we can
talk about that and then whatever else
we
feel like talking about you know yep
after a drink or three
but yeah thank you very much again david
june for sending us the movie we're
gonna watch mask of the phantasm
maybe tonight or tomorrow night we'll
see so we might do a review of that one
eventually as well uh so yeah we enjoyed
that very much
so thanks everybody for dropping by and
we will see you guys tomorrow evening at
5 p.m eastern standard time
and we'll see you then bye
[ __ ] yard work